hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel where today we are talking
about doom eternal I just got to play
three hours at a preview event that's on
top of the maybe like 20-30 minutes I
got to play at e3 last year so I've
bitten off you know a slight chunk of
this game that it says will take about
22 hours to finish in my experience
whatever the developers say ends up
being maybe like five hours longer than
the game actually is so I'm expecting
like a 15 to 20 hour game but I did take
a bunch of questions on an Instagram
post to answer for everyone's questions
about doom eternal I do want to start
this video off by saying I think if doom
eternal had come out in 2019 it would be
game of the year I think it is very
difficult to compete with everything
else in 2020 so I ultimately don't know
but this game is shaping up to be very
good to also give you some of my
background with doom I have played every
single doom game I love doom 1 it might
actually be one of my favorite games
like the literal original doom I I
really love it a lot and I think doom
2016 is fantastic albeit a little bit
buggy and definitely with some
repetitive environment stuff there but
that's that blob drum 81 said did Nick
Gordon deliver his greatest soundtrack
for eternal as 2016 doom from what I
heard yeah the soundtrack is incredible
and the sound mixing specifically in
Doom eternal really blew my mind it's
great in doom 2016 the way that you know
songs constantly feel like they're
building and then cut somehow neatly
every time the fight is done but there
was something about the way in a tunnel
that it built up and then built back
down that seemed even smoother the wreck
since ed did you play on PC and if so
does the movement feel sticky then he
made a comparison to Wolfenstein 2 I did
play on PC and know the movement did not
feel sticky it's very fast smooth I do
think Wolfenstein mechanically is a
little less impressive as a shooter
though I love the story in the world of
Wolfenstein a lot especially those
recent two games but no it is extremely
fast I did have some minor issues with
platforming and there is a lot more
platforming in a tunnel then there
wasn't doom 2016 the platforming is also
smarter honestly the biggest difference
between the two games I think is is doom
2016 is just a lot more fighting doom
eternal still has fighting but it feels
like it's paced a little differently
there are environmental puzzles a lot
more often and platforming that breaks
up combat not to say there is any less
combat it's just that it's broken up
more smartly I feel like in Doom 2016
they would break up comment just by
having you walk in a certain direction
for a while or something like that they
would just give you a corridor where
there's less combat in those segments in
doom eternal you were doing a puzzle or
platforming or something a little more
engaging than just walking so
platforming maybe sometimes felt a
little off to me I wouldn't grab
something the way that I intended to and
I definitely had those issues in 2016
it's definitely refined in at all and
you know there are some trial and error
elements of a tunnel that I really loved
that I loved in 2016 as well where you
enter a room and you die because you've
not yet figured out how about room works
and they the devs did say that combat is
supposed to feel like puzzles like they
all combat puzzles those what they are
you enter a room you assess the enemies
you need to take out and one order you
leave some of the smaller guys so you
can consume them for health I feel like
that is still very much there in a
tunnel and in order for that puzzle to
play out smoothly you have to have a
smooth gameplay and they absolutely do
but no to answer the question movement
does not feel sticky movement feels
extremely smooth fluid I felt very in
control nerd said did they try to add
too many new things I don't think so
the biggest thing that feels very
different to me is that the environments
are all different and all feel new
I saw three vastly different
environments one that was a city one
that was hellish and then one that was
an ice planet and they said that that
environment variety was a direct
response to people complaining that doom
2016 is a little too samey all
repetitive but of course there's also a
hub world now doom Slayer goes back to
his like hub ship which can be upgraded
you get a lot of your weapons there you
can do like a simple training course
there yeah it's essentially like a fast
travel point and a hub world and I don't
know that I feel like that is necessary
I'm unsure
if I like it or not based on the amount
of time that I've played I think maybe I
would prefer to have a campaign that
just keeps pushing me through the the
carnage but I can't say that confidently
I'm not positive I'm actually currently
undecided on how I feel about that hub
world but for the most part no I do not
feel like they added too many new things
it just it feels great Jas and is said
my question is if doom 2016 is a 10 what
is doom eternal doom 2016 is not a 10 I
know a lot of people do really love that
game and I really like it too I really
do but it's buggy and it is repetitive I
think Douma tunnel is better than Tim
2016 I think it is an improvement on a
very very very good call Daniel JJ be
hey arias did you get any play with the
hub world and is it akin to the
submarine from wolf to it's nowhere near
as interesting as either of the hub
worlds in the Newell Wolfenstein games
it's very much just a ship you have to
power certain areas to open them up but
you know Wolfenstein those hub worlds
are so good because they have so much
personality I frankly think they're like
some of the best hubs in any video game
ever do isn't trying to do that because
doom isn't trying to be a game about the
people you collect along the way and who
they are and how their rooms reflect
their personalities it's not trying to
be that game so no it is nowhere near as
interesting but I don't think that
matters all night Chris said I had a
blast exploring all the environments
into 2016 to find secrets how does the
exploration feel in a tunnel I think
that solution is a little more
interesting because there are more
approaches so for anyone who doesn't
know now you can also climb you can wall
climb and there are Assassin's Creed
style like Baz that you jump to and
swing off of which like to picture the
doom Slayer doing as we've known him for
a very long time is a little bit silly
what is he spending his spare time in a
children's playground I don't know but
because of those two things and the wall
climbing story is very much like Tomb
Raider like you or Darkseid is even I
mean there are a million games that have
done it you see a wall that is a
different texture that clearly you can
jump on you jump towards it you hit II I
believe on a keyboard and then grab it
climb up sometimes they'll even be
things you have to avoid on the wall so
you
like climb left and right but having
those things in environments means that
there's more to look out for when it
comes to secrets like I did find one
that was one of those walls that you
could jump to that I would not have
noticed if I didn't have to be looking
off that specific cliff where I saw it
was like I can probably jump to that
jump to it climb around find a secret so
yeah i think i think that's improved it
was already very good its improved
that's probably gonna be most of my
synopsis of doom eternal the thing was
good you made it better
Crump Baraka said is it even good
footage we've seen so far looks like a
real downgrading graphics and attention
to detail what have people been saying
that have I missed people saying oh
that's insane graphically I want to say
it was sort of similar I don't feel like
the two look vastly different but I'm
also never very perceptive when it comes
to graphics now there's not a thing that
my brain pays a tremendous amount of
attention to so unless you put it side
by side I probably wouldn't be able to
tell you I thought doing 2016 was
beautiful I think Douma tunnel is also
beautiful I will say I did have some
bucks the game crashed on me I had a
loading bug where it would hit 65% and
then stop loading that happened a few
times so I very much understand why they
decided to delay a tunnel to give it
more time for polish but none of them
were any worse than bugs I've seen at
any other preview event frankly I think
the only game I've ever previewed that
didn't have a bug was red dead
redemption - Niall asked you said the
amount of new elements to movement in
combat looks quite intensive is it
overwhelming or does it come fairly
naturally extremely naturally I mean it
is intense the gameplay is designed to
be intense there's no rest for the
wicked doom is very full on but
extremely natural and intuitive to play
braxton 880 hope they got rid of the
weak point [ __ ] doom is most fun
when it's fast paced and not stupid
mini-boss garbage also [ __ ] shields doom
is not halo you have some strong
opinions sir they did not get rid of
weak points those still exist but you
know you don't need to use those you can
completely ignore it and still have a
great time and I did feel like this one
was more nostalgic I don't remember all
of the enemies names but um just the the
regular men with the guns with the glowy
eyes from Doom one
back in Douma tunnel as they were not in
2016 I actually feel like there might
have been more enemy variety in eternal
than in 2016 and that's saying something
because I feel a first shooter it has a
tremendous amount of enemy variety in
any case but it felt yeah for some
reason you Tonto feels more nostalgic to
me I think because of the way some
things look I guess I don't know gives
my time it said does the story connect
with doom 2016 and a whole generation of
Slayers stuff the story directly
connects to toon 2016 scotty 1 182 said
how much the climbing did you do that is
the only part from what I've seen it
looks not fun plenty of climbing it's
scattered throughout all of the levels
pretty much uh is it not fun no I don't
think it's not fun I had one platforming
segment where the platforms would fall
from below my feet if I stood on them
for too long and there are also like
things prohibiting you from going
forward like lasers or something that
felt a little less fun to me when I
would prefer to be shooting stuff but
aside from that all of the climbing is
very quick and as a result is fun it
feels like you're surveying an area in a
different way to how you normally would
it's well spaced apart it's quick yeah I
have no complaints other than one very
minor nitpick that caught me off guard
for a while which I technically feel is
more my fault than their fault but it
still feels like a strange design choice
you jump you pressed e but if you
continue to hold e you will fall but
usually if you hold EXO you holds the
climb button you can continue climbing
for whatever reason in a tunnel if you
keep holding that button you will fall
that feels very unnecessary to me and
was something that I had to like
remember every time maybe that's the way
of trying to add an extra component of
challenge there I'm not sure one thing
that I will say I liked about climbing
is they they use some secrets with
climbing puzzles so you might see a 1up
floating in the air or armor floating
somewhere and you'll see it from far
away and know that the only way you can
get that thing is by climbing and
jumping between like climbing platforms
basically and I thought that was cool it
definitely makes you look at
environments much more differently than
you would have in dune 2016 some people
asking me like how I feel about the
weapon
which is my favorite did they feel
different I mean the shotguns always
been my favorite and doom but I don't
know if a lot of people played doom like
this I know that I do and I really love
that about doom is I'd change weapons
constantly depending on what I'm
fighting so I'm gonna use a shotgun
upgraded to have that extra blast with a
caki demon I'm going to use my rocket
launcher on a manky bus I for whatever
reason tend to always use my chainsaw on
a revenant so I am like always swapping
weapons depending on what I'm fighting
and you know they all feel great they
continue to all feel great in a tunnel I
didn't try any new weapons though I
don't know if there are any I mean the
weapon variety and doom 2016 it was
already so good that I don't feel like
it needs its needs new weapons but that
would probably be later in the game we
were playing from the very start of the
game so I imagine if they're going to
introduce new things like I am expecting
the sword that will happen later in the
game there are a couple of people asking
if they should play this as that first
doom and I think that would be fine doom
2016 is great so I recommend playing it
anyway but I imagine you would
understand completely if you just played
to him a tunnel if I'm Atkinson and
Atkinson drew said have the game demos
we've seen from e3 and a likes giving us
an accurate representation of gameplay
it's so smooth and seamless can't help
but feel like some of those trailers
were too good no that is exactly how the
game plays it's very good terms the
story presentation is the most cinematic
approach with more involve cutscenes and
expanded voice acting building upon the
story overall or is it minimal fuel
gameplay story still felt very minimal
to me and it's something that you can
often - if you want to like you can read
all the logs if you want to there's
definitely more of a direction in
eternal where you are hunting down these
three specific people they're speaking
to you I know I guess you know what the
Lord does feel a little more intentional
and calculated and intense but I don't
want to say that it's like more effort
to be cinematic like it's not like
they're hitting you over the head this
isn't the last of us like they're not
trying to make a narrative masterpiece
but I do think they tried harder but
just not in a way that I feel like it
shoves it down your throat it's not
you could still ignore it just fine and
have a great time how do you feel about
the new dash mechanic oh yeah - is Doug
that's something I haven't spoken about
yet you can - to avoid enemies and -
midair - basically instead of doing a
double jump - a triple jump it's just
like a launch it launches you very far -
feels great that's something that uh
really when I started playing a tunnel I
was like I wish I had a - option I wish
I had some way to quickly evade maybe
it's more explosive and that's why I
felt like it needed it and then I
unlocked - and I was like this is
exactly what I was wanting but it's it's
very very seamless honestly I feel like
I'm just saying very positive things
about this but I only have positive
things to say it's dope it's a really
good day I really like it
I got us about the hook but I didn't get
to try that yeah I just feel like a lot
of people are kind of saying like with
all the added stuff and it's really not
that much does the game feel too
different or does it stop feeling fluid
like it does in 2016 but the answer is
ultimately not and I think that's pretty
much it
ultimately I really like it it's a good
game and I do have some gameplay that I
captured so I will throw some of that up
sometime in the next couple of weeks so
you can just see the actual gameplay
it would have edited that into this
video but I unfortunately left the hard
drives elsewhere already friends let me
know if you have any more questions I'm
Alana I will see you guys next time